we are swimming in a culture and built
on a delusion but my accent was a huge
impediment when I started speaking
people would last literally I have to
get up and ask this question because
it's the most important question the
motivation
what's your top ten with believe nation
she's Arianna Huffington and here's my
take on her top ten rules a success
volume to enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one put your own oxygen mask on first we
are swimming in a culture and built on a
delusion the delusion that burnout is
the way to succeed and for me that's the
first thing that an entrepreneur needs
to dispel for themselves that myth and
to recognize that on the contrary as
they tell us on aeroplanes you need to
put your own oxygen mask first and
that's not self-indulgent that doesn't
mean you don't really care enough for
your business that means that you are
taking the most important step towards
having a thriving business rule number
two keep on going I discovered the
Cambridge Union the university's famed
debating society but my accent was a
huge impediment when I started speaking
people would last literally on Monday
there is a debate on the English legal
system the exact motion is the present
English legal system is incompatible
with justice but I kept going I
literally taught myself to speak at the
Union rule number three get more sleep
when Jeff Bezos for example wrote on
thrive and peace the headline she chose
was yes why am i sleeping eight hours a
night is good for Amazon shareholders it
went crazy viral had a big impact on
people yes because he analyzed his
decision-making yes and he said the
value of bring to Amazon is the quality
of my decisions and if I get six hours
if I get less than my optimal eight
hours here's analyzed that his decisions
are five to twenty percent less good
rule number four don't be afraid to fail
what I say to everyone as the best
business advice has to do who's not
being afraid to fail
because so many business people so many
entrepreneurs don't even start on an
idea because they're afraid may fail and
there's a good chance that it may fail I
mean I when when we were ready to start
the Huffington Post I have you have no
idea how many people were trying to
dissuade me from doing it and I mean
people who loved me forget the rest on
the grounds that why do you need that
you know the Internet is a young
person's business you are a successful
author why do you need to risk your
success etc so so being willing to fail
and recognizing as my mother used to
tell us that failure is not the opposite
of success it's a stepping stone to
success that is key also if you want to
learn from more successful female
entrepreneurs check out my to 54 series
the link is free it's an inscription
below when I'm not joyful I look at what
happened rule number five delegate I
think delegating is incredibly important
a lot of entrepreneurs think everything
is to go through them and it becomes
really a complete mess because a they
can't possibly know everything and B
they become a stumbling block for
decisions you know if everything has to
go through them so I had to learn to
hire great people and to delegate not to
micromanage so here let's take a thrive
I heard a fantastic CEO we used to run
Survey Monkey who had a lot of knowledge
about setting up infrastructures and
processes and quarters for salespeople
and bholu systems and all the things you
need to get right to be able to deliver
a profitable company when I left the
Huffington Post that took a couple of
amazing people with me whom I knew
extremely well which is also a great
advantage you know one of them had
joined the Huffington
as in inter so he had been with me for
12 years and he is now running the
global expansion of life the other one
used to be my chief of staff and he's
now running biz dev so this is just a
few examples of bringing great talent
with you and not living under this
delusion that hey I super woman know
everything I'm going to do everything
because a I don't know everything and B
I'm not going to be as good if I try to
do everything rule number six reconnect
neuroscience tells us that it takes less
than one minute to course-correct the
problem is not stressed we're not going
to eliminate stress completely the
problem is stress becoming cumulative so
you have a stressful meeting and then
you've gone to another thing and bring
the stress with you if you took one
minute to take deep breaths to look at
something that helps you course-correct
with pictures of your kids it could be a
quote that you love I have quotes that I
love all around my office my favorite is
leave life as though everything is
rigged in your favor I love that quote I
love that quote I haven't say in that
weeks now telling everyone who will
listen I have a few little quad cards
laminated in my wallet I'll give you a
few when you're backstage
okay so in terms of vacation what is
most important is it's better to have a
short vacation but really disconnect
then a long vacation where you try to
take phone calls and be on conference
calls you know I'm I was talking to
Barry summers he's actually the head of
Private Wealth globally at at JPMorgan
and he said I learned the hard way that
if I'm on vacation and I think I'm going
to do this one conference call what does
it matter the truth is your whole
movement mode of behavior changes you
are suddenly back at work you have to
prep then after the call you are
thinking
about it so you're away from your
vacation time with your family or your
friends or whoever you are with so I
think it's better to at least have a few
days when you can really disconnect and
we have an app for that as you would
expect
yes it's called thrive away and leave
you're on vacation and I email you
I'll get if I can email back that says
Jody's on vacation until such-and-such a
day if this is urgent please contact so
and so if it is not email her after that
date this email will be deleted that is
hard but important because if it's the
whole point is that you are going to
have a vacation it can be two days or
two weeks you decide what you can handle
but during that period you're going to
have zero emails in your inbox when was
the last time you had zero emails in
your inbox I think it was the day I
started my job in proximately seven
years ago exactly yes so the point is
that if you don't do that and you have
that excuse me Oh stupid out of office
email what happens with that how often
do you get an out-of-office email and
two minutes later you get an email from
that person you know it doesn't really
mean anything and it you you we need to
kind of have that real disconnect in
order to reconnect yeah and and be
recharged and we all know that really
the best things you bring to work our
creativity are great ideas
problem solving our ability to
collaborate and these are the first
things that are sacrificed yeah
when we are burnt out rule number seven
be connected to your wisdom if we're
going to really
cultivate leaders who will be able to
take us through these turbulent times
they need to be able to first of all see
the icebergs before they hit the Titanic
that's leadership everybody can see the
iceberg after it has hit it has hit the
Titanic Erin Colin who was the CFO of
Lehman Brothers just before Lehman
Brothers went bankrupt wrote a very
moving piece in the New York Times
recently in which she described her life
she said she had no life she was working
around the clock her marriage was
destroyed her relationships were
destroyed and the thing she didn't say
is that only my brothers went bankrupt
so that's the thing that I want
everybody to understand it's not like
it's a trade off like I'm just going to
build this great company and the hell
with my relationships and my life and my
health no you can no longer do that
because the world is moving so fast
change is happening at such overwhelming
speed that if you are not really
connected with your own wisdom your own
intuition if you are not able to listen
to what Steve Jobs called the
whisperings if you're not going to be
able to tap into the zeitgeist to know
what the needs are before even your
customers know what they need people
didn't know then it is an iPod did they
if you don't know all that you're not
going to be able to be an effective
leader remember eight don't sleep with
your phone do you mind if I put my phone
to sleep here on this phone bed here can
you tell us about this phone yes so we
launched thrive in December 2016 so just
over a year ago and there was one
product that I wanted to launch at the
same time with a company and that's this
phone bed it's actually a charging
station we are all addicted to a phone
what we recommend is that you put this
little phone bag charging station
outside all the bedrooms in their home
and then at night everybody puts their
phones to sleep and you put them under
the blanky you talk the mean you say
goodnight and the idea is that why the
phone is sleeping and charging you are
sleeping in recharge I love the idea
over 70% of people sleep with their
phones by their bed according to all the
latest science the worst thing you can
do for your sleep is to sleep with your
phone oh yes the phone is the repository
of every project every problem
everything we're dealing with when we're
awake therefore it needs to be separated
from us when we're asleep and recharging
so you can wake up fully recharged and
deal with whatever Life brings us rule
number nine make sacrifices oh there's a
quote that we both love yes by Mark NEPA
yes which is sacrificing and what is not
really important in order to focus on
what is truly sacred yes and so I would
say for example let me tell you some of
my sacrifices I have not seen a single
episode of Game of Thrones I would like
to but it's a sacrifice I'm willing to
make I also do a regular life audit and
look at what are the projects that I put
down sometimes I don't even put them
down in writing but in my head it's like
I want to do this or I want to do that
and they are like files that you open on
your computer and you need to close them
if you are not going to do them just so
sweep it clean yeah so what I do is like
for example one of my open computer
files in my brain was I want to learn to
be a good skier because my children love
to ski my two daughters and I think it's
fun to do something like that together
and I'm a lousy skier and then I kind of
realized that I'm not going to give the
time and attention it takes to become a
good skier so I have this rule which is
called I can complete a project by
dropping it and rule number 10 the last
one before a very special bonus clip is
work
I'm wondering how you feel your life may
have been different if you had this
perspective and mentality when you're 18
years old versus now and if for some
reason it meant you may not have been at
top of your game but still a successful
journalist in some regard maybe
differently than you are now would that
have been okay so I have to get up and
ask this question because it's the most
important question and I really think
this is the key to whether thriving as a
movement as a way of living our lives
differently works or not and this is
because I totally understand why you're
asking this question because when you
look around you see that the majority of
people we know about were successful are
workaholics so you look around and you
say hey they succeeded because they
worked around the clock and they were
always there available etc so it's but
there is no correlation that's what I'm
here to tell you and again our seventies
conversation with opera right one of the
super successful people we know and I
just taped super soul Sunday with her
which is airing on Mother's Day and we
both agreed that if Oprah had not worked
as hard as she did including as she said
often going to bed at night with her
clothes on because she was too tired to
take them off she would still be Oprah
but you would have had a much better
time of it because what makes her Oprah
is not that she worked round the clock
but all the great gifts and talents and
abilities to connect with people and
that is a hers it's not a function of
how hard she works and what makes me me
is whatever talents I have and what
makes Rachael Rachael are her talents
and what makes you you you are your
talents and gifts and whatever is a
unique personality that's what makes us
us and then I'm not for a minute
suggesting one another to work hard I
work hard now I'm suggesting working
stupidly and not regenerating and not
renewing ourselves which only make us
better at work I've got a special bonus
gift from Arianna
how to not chase work-life balance that
I think you're going to enjoy but before
that is time for the three-point landing
questions that's all from just watching
a video to taking action here we go
question number one where can you work
smarter number two how can you
experiment with getting more sleep this
week and number three where are you
afraid to fail and just need to get
started work-life balance is a myth you
can call it work life integration Jeff
Bezos calls it work life harmony the key
is that there's never going to be a day
when everything is balanced you know 50%
work 50% family we're not talking about
that we are talking about refueling so
there may be a time when you pull an
all-nighter I mean I obviously emphasize
sleep but I think that all-nighters yes
I mean let's say the day before we
launch thrive we're all in the office
pulling an all-nighter the question is
how quickly do you refuel hmm the next
I've you can do it the next day or the
day after that we even in our cultural
values are thrive we have something that
we call thrive time we don't say this is
a nine-to-five job yeah there are no
interesting nine-to-five jobs
if you want more area and I check it the
first top ten rules video I made on her
the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there we are
afraid of failing when I'm not joyful I
look at what happened we have a
dedicated section called good news
section it only has good news